in 1996 its software offered gamers a
new exciting way to play and compete
that year marked the true birth of
eSports and it began with the land party
in Dallas Texas fans came together to
play a fast-paced revolutionary new
shooter called quake it offered them a
new way to compete and the best of the
best were finally recognized as
professional gamers this year quake
champions takes eSports to the next
level we weren't born champions were
made
made better
made faster
[Music]
made deadlier with every single match
we don't just play we compete
[Music]
we achieve
we rise
we won't stop until we're the best
till we are quake champions
Oh No stop
[Music]
[Applause]
juice it up baby
what's the matter lose something you'll
regret that
cute on
try to keep up
Oh who's next
you've done messed up now I'm coming for
you
goddamn weirdos
none of you get that alive
you win it all comes down to this every
match every frag every victory more than
20 years in the making
the original eSport returns
announcing the quake World Championships
August 26 at QuakeCon in Dallas Texas
competitors will face off in an ultimate
esports arena to win their share of 1
million dollars and the one thing every
champion seeks legacy
[Applause]
play the beta now and get ready for the
quake World Championships visit quake
calm to learn more